you just learned a lot of new things
about bootstrap in order to complete
this project but how would someone who
already knows bootstrap approach our
same problem lets ass shot can find out
to continue our series of throwing
random things at him to get his
attention let's throw this ginormous
penguin so we're gonna actually take
this design and go through it with
bootstrap and turn it into at least a
first pass with HTML and CSS
okay so here's an image that we've been
given by a designer and I'm just going
to go through the process that I go
through when I take something like this
and turn it into a web page I'm going to
be using bootstrap and I have a lot of
work knowledge of bootstrap so when I
use classes from bootstrap
don't worry if you don't know them off
the top of your head I use them almost
every day so they're right there for me
but you can go look at the documentation
for bootstrap it is very complete and
they have all kinds of demos and things
like that that you can really dive into
so if there's something you want to do
and you want to see if bootstrap does it
go check out those documents alright so
basically everything on the web is in
boxes at the moment so we start with the
biggest box that's our browser the the
whole page here and we'll work down from
there if I'm looking at a design like
this I'm gonna start picking out those
boxes and so the first one would be this
this top area here with the logo and the
name there's an HR a horizontal rule
that cuts through everything here we
have this center area with the main
image and then we've got a box down here
that has the featured work and then sort
of the contents of that and so that
would be my first cut and what I'm
looking at that I'm also seeing in this
for instance in this featured work area
there are three boxes three sets of
content they're all identical and I'll
probably just be splitting that whole
row up into these three columns same
with the top here where we have a box
that the logos in and a box that the
name is in so
I go through it and I look at it first
it's really helpful to work through the
image in your head first and sort of
understand where your boxes are it'll
make coding it up a lot easier okay so
jumping into the code here this is sort
of just my starting my jumping-off point
this is mostly just boilerplate I'll
walk through it really quickly here
we're basically just telling the browser
that yes we're HTML we're setting our
doctype we're saying the language in
this case is English we're setting our
character set here that basically just
make sure that the browser is displaying
the characters in the way that I intend
it to the next meta tag down here is
just telling Internet Explorer use the
best engine you've got give the user the
most up-to-date experience the meta tag
here is for mobile and what we're saying
is just sort of how to display the page
initially when it loads there's a title
tag you should always name your pages
we'll call this the the puppy portfolio
the thing below that is actually us
bringing bootstrap into this page and
that's pretty much it for our for the
head of our document the body is where
we're going to start putting in the page
itself so when we start up with
bootstrap we're going to put everything
inside of the bootstraps container and
then going back to our mock here we'll
just start with this top section so I'm
gonna have I'm gonna make a row with the
logo and the name in it now I'm using
I'm going to just split this right down
the middle we might decide to do it a
little off-center or something like that
but for right now I'm just gonna cut it
down the middle everything in bootstrap
is done in twelve columns so the whole
width is divided up into twelve
different columns and so we'll start out
splitting it in half six reach so we'll
drop in our logo here in images it'll be
logo dot PNG always make sure you set
alt text alt text allows people to see
and understand your website when maybe
the image didn't load or if they're
visually impaired their screen reader
will read the contents of this instead
of obviously being able to display that
image to them
all right so here we're gonna put in the
name at this whole area over here this
Jane Doe it and her subtitle and I'm
just going to put these in heading tags
right now the h1 in general is the most
important thing the title the largest
piece the largest heading on the website
and then go down from from there so now
if we go over to our page we actually
have we have our logo and we have our
name but you'll notice that the name
doesn't we're not really looking a whole
lot like our mock at the moment the mock
is right aligned and capitalized and
here we are left aligned and normally
capitalized so if we apply a style to
this mb6 div here this the container of
that name of the name and the subtitle
we're actually going to apply those
Styles across everything
now bootstrap has some nice built in
methods text right and text uppercase
and those will pull all of the text to
the right side and those will set the
text to all the uppercase and again
don't expect in all these going out the
gate bootstraps documentation is is
really good about this and if you
browsing through there you'll just pick
up things every time you look at it it's
not refreshing our page there we go now
we've our text is on the right
everything's capitalized and we'll move
on from there so the next thing I'm
looking at in the mock is this
horizontal rule and we'll drop that in
next
all right so you'll notice that the
horizontal rule for boots step is very
thin we can come back and address that
later right now we're just gonna go
through with just the vanilla
capabilities of bootstrap and we'll
worry about fine-tuning and doing all
that kind of stuff later
so going back to our mock the next thing
up is this big sort of central image
here so that I'll be taking up all
twelve columns and we'll drop that in so
sorts of our images will be any images
so now if we go to our page there's a
puppy one of the things that you'll
notice is that it's actually coming off
the edge of the screen here it's
actually overflowing its container and
so we can go and we can use a bootstrap
class responsive which will make sure
that that image pulls itself in to fit
inside of its of its parent container so
that that called the twelve columns this
image now fits inside of it so there's
our there's our first puppy now the
puppies are starting to make sense let's
go back to our mock the next section
we're gonna work on here is just this
featured work so we'll consider featured
work to be its own twelve columns wide
and then we'll have each one of these
sort of featured work elements be their
own four columns wide each for call
fours each and we'll just split it up
and we're going to just work through it
top to bottom
featured work is sort of the second most
important title on our page it's a
section heading here so we're gonna use
an h2 you can flip back and forth in
between your browser and your coding
environment to make sure that you know
sort of just sanity check along the way
but when we have repeated elements like
this we can actually just code them up
once and copy and paste that it in this
case a couple X more times and then
update the elements within it it'll save
us a little bit of typing a little bit
of time
all right so there's our there's our
puppy there's our title so let's add
again that name it's responsive we'll
just make sure that that puppy stays
inside of his of his little container so
now we've got one of them we can just
copy paste over a few more times and
then modify those and we should be
coming up close to what our to what our
mock looks like let's go grab that text
and we'll just do some updates here now
I'm copying and pasting to save myself a
little bit of time typing but make sure
when you copy paste that you actually
are updating that everything that you
need to update it's very easy to
introduce errors when you're typing and
pasting because you might not see one of
the minor differences so maybe it's not
changing this image source or not
changing the alt text just go through
and make sure that you're that you're
really thorough when you copy/paste it's
a shortcut but make sure you don't take
it too casually alright so there are our
featured work